afriso das bringt doch alles nichts
ich wollte ja eigentlich gerade in texte
war dann neuesten kuh schreiben du weißt
schon die zerstörung der presse aber ich
habe es mir anders überlegt denn wenn
wir ehrlich sind werden die meisten der
2,7 millionen menschen die sich das
inzwischen angeschaut haben morgen will
er nicht zu fuß gehen und sich die faz
kaufen um zu erfahren warum der coole
typ mit den blauen haaren in wahrheit
nur billige propaganda in eigener sache
betreibt also habe ich mir gedacht wenn
ihr nicht zu uns kommt dann komme ich
her zu euch und mache was philipp amthor
letztes jahr dann leider doch nicht
durchgezogen hat eine selbstverliebte
pseudo sachliche stimmungsmache mal
gründlich auseinandernehmen
zugegeben das war jetzt kein besonders
freundlicher start
da war es doch das kritik besonders dann
gut aufgenommen wird wenn man sie lob ab
und dazu muss ich mich nicht mal
vorstellen denn es gibt an deinem video
ja auch wirklich ein paar aspekte die
richtig positiv sind
also fangen wir doch erstmal mit ein
paar guten dingen an bevor wir zu den
problematischen und dann zu den komplett
indiskutablen teilen des videos komme
also wirklich gut finde ich natürlich
die tatsache dass du dich überhaupt
kritisch mit medien auseinandersetzt und
einzuführen empfiehlt das auch zu tun
das stimmt ja im grundsatz was du sagst
journalisten spitzen manchmal unzulässig
zu sie verpacken haltlose spekulationen
als scheinbar harmlose fragen sie messen
mit zweierlei maß sie missachten
manchmal persönlichkeitsrechte und was
ich an der stelle noch ergänzen würde
sie verhalten sich manchmal auch wie
billige drahtlose opportunisten wenn sie
meinen der konkurrenz eins auswischen zu
können aber dazu später im video noch
mehr
anyway das alles passiert und es
passiert natürlich ungleich häufiger und
heftiger in der regenbogen und
boulevardpresse die du dir ja auch als
erstes vor knast ich weiß nicht ob du
den zuschauern oder überhaupt irgendwem
wirklich fast ein neues erzählt wenn du
darauf hinweist dass in klatschblättern
lauter erfundene geschichten stehen dass
die bild zeitung ist mit ethischen
standards oft nicht so genau nimmt und
für deine doch ziemlich zentrale these
dass solche berichte die anfälligkeit
für verschwörungstheorien steigern die
fast dem ganzen video auch keinen
einzigen beleg
aber es schadet natürlich trotzdem nicht
immer mal wieder ins bewusstsein zu
rufen was für ein müllhaufen besonders
die regenbogenpresse ist in diesem teil
des videos will ich dir auch
überhaupt nicht widersprechen außer
vielleicht wenn du meinst dass diese
klatschblätter ein ganz normaler teil
von medien werden ich glaube die
allermeisten leute begreifen instinktiv
schon ganz genau dass die freizeit revue
und die süddeutsche zeitung nicht nur
zwei paar schuhe sind sondern dass die
schuhschränke nicht mal auf demselben
planeten stehen als nächstes nimmst du
dir dann die boulevardpresse vor also in
erster linie die bild zeitung und den
westen aber auch einzelne texte aus dem
sternen der münchner abendzeitung der
welt und im fokus hier geht es um die
kampagne gegen christian drosten um die
veröffentlichung von fotos auf denen
frauen versehentlich teilweise mehr
nackte haut gezeigt haben als sie
eigentlich wollten und um berichte die
die privatsphäre von verbrechensopfern
oder ihren angehörigen verletzen oder
personen in gefahr bringen und wieder
eine aufzählung ja schon zeigt kommt das
nicht nur bei der bild zeitung vor
sondern wenn auch deutlich seltener auch
bei seriösen medien auch hier machst du
viele korrekte punkte und die von dir
angesprochenen texte empfinde ich auch
als schweinerei
es hätte allerdings auch zur ordnung
gehört diese medien erst mal vorher zu
fragen ob sie vielleicht irgendeine
erklärung dafür haben und diese dann
auch wieder zu gehen
das macht man sollte rio journalist
leute erst mal nach ihrem standpunkt
fragen bevor man sie öffentlich an den
pranger stellt weißt du anscheinend
nicht jedenfalls haben wir alle medien
angeschrieben die in deinem video
irgendwie kritisch vorkommt und sie
gefragt und du sie vorher um eine
stellungnahme gebeten hast und es haben
uns bisher zwar noch nicht alle
geantwortet aber diejenigen die sich
gemeldet haben haben allesamt gesagt
nein du hättest dich vorher nicht
gemeldet dube schwerst sich auch das
seriöse medien sich nicht genug von der
boulevardpresse distanzieren und im
gegenteil sogar regelmäßig auf deren
artikel verweist aber die seriöse
zeitungen auch ihr habt eine große
verantwortung in dieser sache damit man
nämlich weiß dass eure standards höher
sind solltet ihr vielleicht klarer
machen dass ihr euch von diesen
bezeichnungen distanziert ich meine wir
leser können zum beispiel ständig sehen
dass ihr auf deren berichte seriös
verweist das gibt uns erst mal das
gefühl dass ihr sie als seriöse kollegen
an seht dass sie eine bestimmte näher
fühlt dass wir grundsätzlich in
denselben topf gehört und wenn ihr dann
auf dieser basis zu solchen abgefragten
muss einfach schweigt dann braucht ihr
euch nicht wundern wenn leser nicht
wissen ob ihr das duldet gut findet oder
vielleicht selber so machen würde
im gegensatz zur regenbogenpresse wird
die boulevardpresse tatsächlich immer
wieder auch von seriösen zeitung und
zitiert da hast du schon recht für
diesen rat gibt es aber auch einen
ziemlich einleuchtenden sachlichen grund
im gegensatz zu regenbogenpresse stehen
in der bild -zeitung eben nicht nur
belanglosigkeiten und unterhalten
die bild hat eine der grössten redaktion
des landes mit sie bringt immer wieder
auch schon als sich relevante
geschichten mit echten nachrichtenwert
aus die wir dann eben auch zitieren zb
hier zu verdachtsfällen auf betrug bei
den crooner helfen oder hier wenn jetzt
sparen zu bild sagt das auf keinen fall
der eindruck entstehen dürfe die
pandemie sei schon vorbei oder auch hier
wenn die bild mit als erste berichtet
dass der langjährige
bundestagsabgeordnete johannes kahrs aus
der politik ausscheidet das kann der
rest der presse nicht einfach ignorieren
die lage ist hier nun mal einfach etwas
komplizierter ist gibt in der bild
geschichten die ethische standards
unterschreiten aber es gibt eben auch
andere die wichtig sind und die wir dann
auch erwähnen müssen also wie könnte in
so einer situation wohl ein vernünftiges
vorgehen aus sind vielleicht so dass man
die gehaltvollen geschichten aufgreift
über die bild gleichzeitig auch scharf
kritisiert wenn sie mal wieder mit haut
drauf journalismus punkten will dass er
ja quasi genau die distanzierung die du
forderst und moment mal was haben wir
denn hier sieht ja fast so aus als wir
genau das was du forderst längst machen
würden und wie nennt man das noch mal
wenn man ein verhalten an greift das gar
nicht stattfindet stroman argument
vielleicht mensch wenn nur jemand mal
ein video über sowas machen würde
hier geht es jetzt um fragen stellen und
konjunktive benutzen also hätte könnte
müsste um es kurz zu machen
auch hier hast du natürlich ein punkt es
ist wirklich eine verbreitete und
beliebte technik aussagen die man als
journalist nicht belegen kann trotzdem
als frage in den raum zu stellen oder
sich auf eine angebliche
mehrheitsmeinung zu berufen die in
wahrheit einfach nur die eigene meinung
ist ich finde dieses beispiel findet zum
beispiel sehr treffend und auch
berechtigt so ein journalist der auch
herausgeber von handelsblatt ist
schreibt zum beispiel die bevölkerung
denkt über wirtschaftsminister peter
altmaier wenig vorteilhaft pausen rund
und ihnen zu luftig really die
bevölkerung denkt dass hass dafür belege
einfach so hast du gar nicht belegt
komisch dabei gab es doch neulich erst
die große ist peter altmaier rund und
luftig umfrage bei der wir alle
teilgenommen haben
ich schätze es nicht warum kann die
saison ist nicht einfach das rückgrat
haben den altmaier fett und holt so
nennt wenn er genau das sagen möchte
aber auch hier ist die lage dann halt
doch nicht ganz so simpel wie du sie
darstellt denn es kann natürlich auch
völlig legitim sein sich auf
stimmungslagen zu berufen die erkennbar
innerhalb einer bestimmten gruppe
bestehen oder fragen zu stellen auf die
man selber keine antwort hat oder auch
solche auf die man vielleicht schon eine
antwort hat aber die man eben trotzdem
als irgendwie umstritten oder nicht
offensichtlich markieren möchte nehmen
wir doch mal ein paar beispiele aus
deinem video ist das grundgesetz
tatsächlich in gefahr
es tut genau das man nimmt eine
spekulative behauptung fügten
fragezeichen dazu ganz ehrlich wo liegt
denn hier bitteschön das problem der
betreffende artikel greift eine sorge
auf die von vielen bürgern aber auch von
angesehenen rechtswissenschaftlern in
der kubakrise eindrücklich formuliert
wurde
es ist also nicht so als würde hier nun
eine völlig haltlose absurde nischen
meinung als frage formuliert sondern
eben eine frage die man sich durchaus zu
recht stellen konnte auch wenn man sich
ebenfalls zu recht im ergebnis verneinen
muss was der artikel ja auch tut
denn den nächsten beispiel ist es zum
teil sogar noch abwegige wo zum beispiel
ist das problem mit der überschrift was
hat bill gates mit corona zu tun
der text erschien zu einer zeit als
zehntausende menschen auf die straße
gingen um gegen die angebliche
weltverschwörung zu demonstrieren
da konnte man sich als jemand der das
jetzt nicht im detail verfolgt hat doch
wohl zu recht genau diese frage stellen
was hat bill gates denn bitteschön mit
corona zu
und es gibt auf diese frage ja auch eine
klare antwort die der artikel dann auch
liefert nämlich das geld sich über seine
stiftung in der entwicklung von
impfstoffen engagiert will gates uns
alle mit mikrochips zwangs impfen lassen
wäre eine unzulässige und suggestive
überschrift gewesen aber die hier
gewählte ist noch einwandfrei oder noch
ein beispiel dieser text von der welt
zur corona pandemie hat nicht nur dieses
jahr ich stelle die frage im titel
sondern ist auch komplett pur
ausgedachte spekulation über alles
mögliche schlimme was passieren könnte
aber es ist halt nicht von irgendeinem
fantasie autor dann geschrieben als
kurzgeschichte im kulturteil der zeitung
oder so sondern vom ressortleiter der
wirtschaft im wirtschafts teilen diese
pure fantasie spekulationen steht
einfach zwischen ganz normal nachrichten
und beeinflusst da die leser so was ist
nicht cool und letztlich auch nur eine
schöner geschriebene form von einem das
ist es ja vielleicht möglicherweise ist
das vielleicht der titel ist am 21 märz
erschienen als ich die krise hierzulande
gerade so richtig hoch schaukeln und das
völlig offen war wie dramatisch der
verlauf werden würde zu dem zeitpunkt
waren tatsächlich alle möglichen
szenarien plausibel denkbar
der autor schreibt übrigens gleich ganz
zu anfang des beitrags das ist absolut
möglich ist dass wir gestärkt aus der
krise hervorgehen werden und dass die
politik und die wirtschaft sich bewerben
werden das schreibt dann aber auch aber
es gibt auch eine rest
wahrscheinlichkeit und vermutlich ist
sie nicht ganz klein dass die krise
einen anderen verlauf nimmt
darauf folgt dann ein
unmissverständlicher als spekulation
gemeinter und erkennt licher text wie es
in den nächsten acht wochen weitergehen
könnte
man kann natürlich darüber streiten wie
sinnvoll es ist solche spekulationen zu
verfassen
ebenso gut gehen das gegenteil eintreten
kann und wie wir inzwischen wissen ja
auch tatsächlich in vielen punkten
eingetreten ist aber es ist eben auch
völlig legitim und zur
entscheidungsfindung doch geradezu
notwendig in einer situation großer
unsicherheit verschiedene
zukunftsszenarien gedanklich
durchzuspielen und sich zu fragen was
passiert wenn die dinge so oder so
verlaufen wenn ich so ein essen nicht
interessiert und du nur harte rein
faktenbasierte nachrichten lesen willst
dass das auch völlig in ordnung aber es
ist absurd dass spekulative aber auf im
grundsatz plausiblen annahmen beruhen
das szenario des felt autors in eine
ecke mit ken jepsen zu stellen der
irgendwelchen schwachsinn von einer
verschwörung der bundesregierung mit
bill gates in die kamera und
dieser abschnitt ist der spannendste
teil des videos und das sehe ich
natürlich auch deshalb so weil ich
selbst bei einer der zeitungen arbeite
überleben widerspricht und obendrein
noch bei derjenigen die bei einer
analyse am schlechtesten weg kommt ich
bin hier also in einer gewissen weise
auch persönlich betroffen zumal in einer
auswertung auch faz texte als fehlerhaft
markiert wurden an denen ich mit
geschrieben habe es geht mir also zum
einen darum die falschbehauptungen die
du bei uns verbreitet ist gerade zu
rücken
zum anderen dürfte das hier aber auch
ein ganz interessantes lehrstück in
sachen medienkompetenz werden denn es
ist doch schon lustig und interessant zu
sehen wie du in diesem teil des videos
genau die art von ihr geführten
unterstellungen verfälschungen und strom
an argumenten benutzt über die du dich
bei den medien so beschwert vielleicht
steckt ja sogar eine art tiefere lektion
drin irgendwas über die schwierigkeit
wahrheit inter subjektiv zu erfassen
oder so war
wir wollen nicht gleich gelöscht werden
also erst mal rein ins vergnügen
du stellst am anfang selbst klar jetzt
wäre es natürlich sie hier einfach
random beispiele von irgendwelchen
fehlern der presse zu zeigen aber damit
hätte ich nichts gezeigt denn fehler
machen wir alle die frage ist also nicht
ob zeitungen fehler machen denn das ist
ja klar sondern die frage ist wie oft
steht in der zeitung etwas faktisch
falsches um diese frage zu beantworten
hast du dir dann folgendes system
ausgedacht und jetzt macht es natürlich
keinen sinn dass ich irgendwie fact
checker bei themen wie wirtschaft oder
klimaschutz wo ich nicht so der derbste
experte bin dass ich sofort jeden fehler
sehe also es wichtig dass ich mir ein
thema rausgepickt habe bei dem ich so
tief drin bin dass wir fehler sofort auf
anja und das thema bei dem ich am
meisten drin bin bin natürlich ich
selbst schon als ich dann wieder zum
allerersten mal angeschaut hat noch
bevor ich da irgendwas gegengecheckt
hatte ist mir an dem punkt ehrlich
gesagt die kinnlade herunter geklappt
die vorstellung dass es irgendwie eine
gute idee sein könnte ausgerechnet die
angebliche fehlerquote in artikeln über
dich selbst zum maßstab der qualität
einer ganzen zeitung zu erklären ist so
dermaßen haarsträubend dass ich wirklich
nicht weiß wo ich überhaupt anfangen
soll
ok also gut ich lege auch hier erst mal
mit dem einen positiven aspekt los der
mir dazu gerade noch einfällt
es stimmt natürlich dass du dich mit dir
selber besser auskennt als mit themen
wie wirtschaft oder klimawandel
auch wenn ich das glaube ich letztes
jahr nicht davon abgehalten hat den
beiden größten deutschen parteien ein
völliges versagen auf genau diesen
feldern zu attestieren
aber wie absurd ist bitte die idee die
qualität einer ganzen zeitung die über
buchstäblich tausende themen berichtet
und korrespondenten in alle ecken der
welt entsendet ausgerechnet an der
fehlerquote in ihren texten zu einem
einzigen thema messen zu wollen selbst
wenn die fehlerquote die du uns und
anderen zeitungen unterstellst wirklich
genau so zutreffen sollte und nicht wie
wir gleich sehen werden komplett an den
haaren herbeigezogen werden würde das
doch trotzdem maximal belegen dass die
kleine zahl von redakteuren die
innerhalb des riesigen apparat zeitung
gerade für die rieso berichterstattung
zuständig sind bei genau diesem einen
thema schlecht gearbeitet haben weil sie
sich vielleicht in der youtube szene
nicht so gut auskennen oder weil sie
irgendwie ein problem mit mir als person
haben oder weshalb auch immer darüber
könntest du dich dann zwar zu recht
beschweren aber es hätte mit der
qualität der jeweiligen zeitung als
ganzes doch wirklich nur am rande zu tun
und in der klar ich weiß auch dass du in
deinem video sagst aber man muss sich
auch vor augen halten dass das jetzt
natürlich keine absolute metrik für die
qualität einer zeitung ist und und
letztlich ist das ja auch kein absolutes
maß über die qualität weil wir eben nur
hunderte artikel ausgewertet haben aber
du sagst hat auch dass hier das ändert
aber alles nichts daran dass tendenzen
sehr klar zu erkennen sind und das ist
natürlich eine gewisse aussagekraft hat
nach der statistik sind faz bild und
welt die unglaubwürdig ssten quellen und
das hier faz bild und welt sind maybe
nicht die glaubwürdigsten quellen okay
dann kriegt das halt weniger an ist ja
in ordnung aber schmeißt nicht die
anderen zeitung in denselben topf ihr
gesehen habt gibt es sichtbare
unterschiede
das heißt also ganz klar dass du
wirklich meins die qualität einer
zeitung in ihren berichten über dich
messen zu können das alleine schon so
sorry vermessen und größenwahnsinnig das
fertig gesagt die worte fehlen
und dann gibt es noch ein zweites ganz
grundsätzliches problem mit seinem
ansatz denn die gute kenntnis die du
über dich selbst hast
wird natürlich um den preis mangelnder
distanz erkauft es liegt doch auf der
hand dass man bei sich selbst dazu neigt
übertrieben pingelig vorzugehen und
selbst kleinste unsauberkeiten die man
in bezug auf jeden anderen auch zu recht
als total nebensächlich ansehen würde
weil sich selbst will superwichtig zu
halten
vor allem natürlich dann wenn diese
unsauberkeiten von einer zeitung kommen
die insgesamt kritisch mit ihr umgeht
ein paar anderen zeitungen kann man dann
natürlich schon mal ein auge zudrücken
kommen wir also zu deiner methodik die
du selber so erklärt also haben lisa aus
meinem team und ich alle artikel von
diesem zeitung gesucht gibt 2009/10
rauskam und das porträt so enthalten das
waren über 1700 stück die sind wir dann
händisch alle durchgegangen und haben
jetzt mal alle artikel aus der statistik
entfernt in denen ich nur so als
randnotiz in einem satz markus vorkommen
also wenn ich zwar genannt werde aber es
geht in dem artikel gar nicht um einen
sachverhalt der mir so nah ist dass ich
direkt fehler sehen würde
dann macht es ja keinen sinn damit waren
immer noch über 400 artikel übrig und
die haben wir dann aufmerksam und
ordentlich gelesen und alle gesteckt und
all das haben wir auch ganz transparent
in einer sehr langen excel-tabelle für
euch aufbereitet ist eine lange liste
unter steht dann wenn ein artikel eine
faktisch falsche behauptung enthält und
auch immer mindestens ein beispiel davon
damit das gut belegt ist so kann jeder
die ergebnisse nachvollziehen und sogar
nachprüfen das finde ich halt
unglaublich wichtig an so einer stelle
auch hier will ich erst noch mal sagen
ich finde es sehr gut dass du dein
vorgehen so transparent macht und jedem
die möglichkeit gibt es gleich
nachzuprüfen ob das was du sagst noch
stimmt davon können sich wirklich viele
medien eine scheibe abschneiden das
problem für dich ist halt nur dass sich
bei der nachprüfung dann leider ergibt
dass du kompletten unsinn erzählt nehmen
wir mal ein paar deiner beispiele aber
es wird schnell kritischer wenn echt
lecker behauptungen über eine gesamte
branche verbreitet werden denn laut
manchen zeitung gehört es zwangsweise
für professionelle youtuber dazu sich zu
verstellen nein lieber rieso das stimmt
einfach nicht
und das zitat dass du hier einwenden ist
verkürzt im original heißt es nämlich
was der cdu so große probleme bereitet
ist schließlich nicht das amateurhafte
eines youtube sondern dessen technische
und inhaltliche professionalität
dazu gehört auch sich zu verstellen auf
jeden zuschauer wird die pose des
einzelkämpfers erst einmal authentisch
der es angeblich gern
allein mit dem adenauer imperium
aufnimmt nachdem er tagelang intensiv
recherchiert hatte die fassade verdeckt
dass es sich um einen unternehmer
handelt der sich beraten sich zu
arbeiten lässt und der genau kalkuliert
es geht hier also einfach die gerade
nicht um alle professionellen youtuber
sondern nur um dich das ist wohl ein
kleiner unterschied man es nicht
nächstes beispiel macht ja auch sinn
schließlich inszenieren figuren wie ich
unsere authentizität nur alles ein
großes fake schauspiel solche
allgemeinen aussagen sind natürlich
völliger bullshit ich glaube ich brauche
ja auch nicht erklären dass nicht jeder
youtuber fähig ist und jeder
authentische wirken inszeniert lieber
wieso das brauchst du tatsächlich nicht
zu erklären denn das haben auch weder
wir noch die kollegen von der sz
behauptet bei uns heißt das wer sieht
wie jugendliche oder auch kinder heute
solche videos konsumieren und wie sehr
sie sich dank ihrer professionell
inszenierten authentizität mit figuren
wie identifizieren wird sich schwer tun
die meinungsbildende macht solcher
figuren und die autorität ihrer
popularität zu unterschätzen
es geht hier also um dich und auch noch
um nicht näher spezifizierte andere
youtuber aber nirgendwo wird behauptet
dass das auf alle professionellen
youtuber zu treffen und bei der es
entschied dass hier
es hat sich eine eigenständige sehr
komplexe und hochgradig codierte kultur
dieser influenza videos entwickelt die
für uneingeweihte vor allem quatsch
wirkt an die zielgruppe aber ganz klare
botschaften senden
denn wichtig ist vor allem die
inszenierung als authentisch im rahmen
des videos dass man nach witze über sich
selbst man zeigt die cutterin und dem
kameramann denn alles soll selbst
gemacht wirken als könne jeder so ein
video drehen obwohl natürlich doch eine
ganze bearbeitungs und
marketingmaschinerie dahinter steht auch
hier wird allgemein über influenza
videos gesprochen aber nicht über die
videos aller professionellen youtuber
und vor allen dingen ist die aussage
dass du und auch viele andere youtuber
sich als authentisch inszenieren auch
einfach zu treffen
das wort inszenierten bedeutet laut
duden ein stück beim theater beim
fernsehen einen film technisch und
künstlerisch vorbereiten und gestalten
und leiten
genau das machst du mit deinem video ob
du dich jetzt als authentisch inszeniert
oder ob du dich einfach nur inszeniert
und dabei authentisch wirkt weil du so
bist ist einfach eine betrachtung und
beurteilung frage unser auto ist der
ansicht dass die art seiner inszenierung
betont darauf angelegt ist
über zu kommen das muss dir nicht
gefallen und das kannst du auch anders
sehen aber das ist natürlich keine
falschbehauptung oder in fakten fehler
sondern wieder mal einfach eine
meinungsverschiedenheit und dabei hast
du im einleitung style deine auswertung
doch sogar extra noch klargestellt dass
fragen bewertung und das nahelegen einer
deutung gerade nicht als fehler in
deinem statistik eingehen sollen
verstehst du langsam was ich damit meine
das ist keine gute idee ist texte über
dich selber auszuwerten weil dir dabei
die kritische distanz fehlt was genau
solchen gründen und weil du einfach
meinungsäußerungen die dir persönlich
nicht passen als falschbehauptungen
bezeichnet und weil die faz ich
vermutlich kräfte und heftiger
kritisiert hat als jede andere deutsche
zeitung gibt es bei uns auch die meisten
dieser falschbehauptung noch ein
beispiel gefällig bitte schön du
schreibst du deine auswertung zu einem
unserer artikel das wirklich angeblich
falsch zitiert hätten
du hättest zwar gesagt dass der csu
channel ein propagandakanal sei aber
nicht deshalb weil dort quellenangaben
fehlten bei uns heißt es derart
peinliche versuch der csu mit den csu
videos ist für ihn aber nicht nur
peinlich sondern ein zitat ziemlich klar
propaganda channel weil man darin auf
quellen verzichte du antwortest darauf
dass das nicht stimmen würde denn du
hättest den channels war schon als
propaganda channel bezeichnet aber eben
weil er klassische propaganda tricks
verwendet wie zum beispiel das nutzen
bildliche assoziationen zwischen den
personen die man negativ darstellen
möchte und vermeintlich negativen
konnotationen aber offenbar nicht weil
er auf quellen verzichtet das zitat um
das es hier geht stammt von der watchdog
19 veranstaltung von der online leider
keine aufnahmen existieren aber unser
autor der damals vor ort bar hat
praktischerweise ein diktiergerät
mitlaufen lassen
also haben wir doch mal ein dass du
wirklich gesagt hast ziemlich klar wo
sie nicht mit quellen kommen wo sie
nicht mit irgendwie klar ich weiß nach
außen ab um es mit deinen worten zu
sagen stellt sich heraus dass unser auto
hat sich doch genau richtig zitiert hat
wir können natürlich sehr wohlwollend
unterstellen dass du dich selber falsch
erinnert hast was du auf der konferenz
gesagt ist aber wie dreist du deinen
zuschauer als nächstes bei einer
behauptung an luxe die wirklich jeder
mit zwei klicks nachprüfen kann das
macht mich dann schon
bisschen sprachlos zum anderen wurde
gesagt ich hätte bedingungen aufgestellt
um mit der cdu grundsätzlich meinungen
auszutauschen oder gespräche zu führen
und das sechste an diesen artikeln ist
dass sie sich alle auf ein statement von
mir beziehen indem ich explizit sage
dass ich bereits in kontakt mit
politikern aus der cdu stehe um
meinungen auszutauschen und diese
gespräche auch weiterhin führen möchte
also ich hab statement heraus indem ich
sage dass ich gespräche mit politikern
führe und das weiterhin tun möchte und
mainz auf soll wichtig ist von zeitungen
sagen ihren lesern genau das gegenteil
blende ist hier mal wieder nur einen
kleinen teil des textes an den du damals
getötet hass und sieh mal an wenn man
ein volles statement liest dann steht da
dass hier
du schreibst hier ausdrücklich dass du
nur dann mit spd und cdu sprechen willst
wenn diese vorab zu geben dass ein
drastischer kurswechsel in der
klimapolitik nötig ist die spd hat das
angeblich getan bei der cdu bist du dir
nicht so sicher du sagst dass du mit
einzelnen politikern auch aus der cdu
rede ist aber eben nur mit solchen die
deiner meinung nach respektvoll
auftreten und die ebenfalls einen
solchen kurswechsel für nötig hätten du
glaubst seine gesprächsbereitschaft ob
mit der partei als ganzer oder mit
einzelnen politikern also glasklar an
eine bedingung nämlich an die einsicht
in die notwendigkeit dieses kurswechsels
obwohl du ja fast 1800 texte in dem
dokument stehen hast hast du letztlich
nur 15 beiträge von uns geprüft von
denen dann angeblich zehn fehler fragen
wie wir gesehen haben ist das in vielen
fällen einfach unwahr
nach unserer analyse befinden sich
lediglich in drei texten über die spiele
und die sind jeweils ziemlich minimal
beschwert sich zum beispiel dass wir
geschrieben haben du hättest auf einer
konferenz von deutschlandradio gesagt
vollständigkeit heiße sein argument
sinnvoll zu führen und fakten zu nennen
tatsächlich aber gesagt vollständigkeit
heißt dein argument sinnvoll zu führen
und das richtig gut raus sagen und da
fakten zu kennen und das habe ich
ziemlich gut durchgezogen das zitat
hätte also heißen müssen fakten zu
kennen statt fakten zu nennen ist jetzt
vielleicht nicht der gravierendste
zitierfehler aller zeiten aber
verringert haben wir korrigiert
oder auch dieser text in dem wir
schreiben dass du deine mitarbeiter
beauftragt hast dich bei der recherche
zu unterstützen also wählte behauptungen
über ey das ist alles nur inszeniert
aufzustellen ohne jeglichen beleg dass
können nicht nur alu hut träger und
speziell zu mir gibt es auch in der
seriösen presse eine menge verschwörungs
erzählung insgeheim hätte ich ein pr
team und ich hatte mehrere mitarbeiter
damit beauftragt über klima berichten zu
brüten
okay du hast also nicht mehrere
mitarbeiter damit beauftragt sich bei
der recherche zu unterstützen sondern
nur einen mitarbeiter
wir haben das damals so geschrieben weil
du in einem interview mit uns gesagt
hast dass du mehrere mitarbeiter
beauftragt und bezahlt hast hunderte
stunden in das video zu investieren aber
gut du hast nicht gesagt was genau sie
in diesen hunderten stunden machen
sollten wenn du jetzt sagst dass du nur
ein mitarbeiter bei der recherche
geholfen hat müssen wir das hinnehmen
und haben auch diesen fehler
entsprechend korrigiert aber den
minimalen unterschied zwischen ein
mitarbeiter und mehrere mitarbeiter
jetzt als verschwörungs erzählung zu
bezeichnen die du in die nähe von armut
trägern rückt ist schon ziemlich absurd
weil sie nicht mit solchen
übertreibungen trägst du selbst zum
verfall des vertrauens in die medien bei
den du in deinem video beklagt
ach und wenn wir schon bei fehlern sind
ja es stimmt jasper von altenbockum hat
letztes jahr einen verunglückten tweet
über dich abgesetzt und sich später in
einer talkshow etwas in seiner antwort
verstolpert wie du selber sagt fehler
passieren jeden mal und auf twitter oder
in einer live situation passieren sie
natürlich auch besonders leicht
ob es deshalb jetzt guter stil ist ein
etwas holprigen satz nach zu erstens sei
mal dahin gestellt
aber es kommt noch viel übler und genau
das ist in diesem part auch genau der
knackpunkt wenn ein innenpolitikchef der
faz verschwörungs erzählung raushaut
sich dabei auf demselben recherche level
wie die ganzen verschwörungs ideologen
auffällt und das in keiner form und art
aufarbeitet dann singt nicht nur seine
glaubwürdigkeit massiv und dauerhaft
sondern eben auch die seiner kollegen
und wenn sich keiner bei dieser zeitung
von diesem verhalten öffentlich
distanziert dann kann ich doch niemandem
übel nehmen wenn man dieser zeitung
grundsätzlich viel weniger vertrauen
schenkt
wäre ein plausibler schluss das ist
wieder eine maßlose übertreibung wie
gesagt der tweet der dich zerstört war
unglücklich formuliert aber die
behauptung er sei auf demselben level
wie verschwörungstheorien ist mal wieder
eine maßlose übertreibung und zu fordern
dass wir uns von jasper von altenbockum
distanzieren müssen als wäre er klasse
los ist einfach eine unverschämte mit
verlaub erste hat für den deutschen
journalismus tausendmal mehr geleistet
als du vermutlich jemals du wirst er
arbeitet seit jahrzehnten bei dieser
zeitung der ist mit vielen von uns auch
privat gut befreundet und wir sollen uns
öffentlich von ihm distanzieren wegen
eines unglücklichen tweets wieso das
sind stalinistische setzt besichtigungs
methoden merkst du eigentlich nicht was
mich an machst du kriegst einen längst
gelöschten tweet raus und vor dass
zwischen den zeilen quasi den rauswurf
des autors mit dem offenbar eine
persönliche vendetta am laufen hast weil
er als einer von leider viel zu wenigen
nicht in die jubelrufe über den cdu
video eingestellt hat schaut vielleicht
noch mal ein bisschen weiter vorne in
deinem video nach was du so zum thema
menschenfeindlichkeit ablässt und dann
schauen wir den spiegel so ist gäbe noch
eine ganze menge weiterer angeblicher
fehler die du bei uns gefunden haben
willst aber ich will hier jetzt auch
nicht auf jeden einzelnen eingehen weil
das einfach zu lange dauern und zu
kleinteilig werden würde aber in jeder
der es genau wissen will findet in den
quellen zu diesem video ein dokument in
die welt jeden deiner kritikpunkt
auflisten und jeweils detaillierte
antworten warum wir das anders sehen bis
in welchen fällen video zu stimmen zum
abschluss dieses teils des videos muss
ich jetzt aber doch glatt noch mal auf
deine statistik zurückkommen
angeblich gab es in der faz im jahr 2000
1970 artikel die deinen namen enthalten
und du hast da allerdings nicht nur
artikel aus der faz sondern auch aus der
fas der woche und vom partner ist dabei
aber gut von mir aus fassen wir das
alles motto der überschrift faz zusammen
bloß gibt es da ein klitzekleines
problem der name so taucht im jahr 2019
laut unserem archiv nämlich gar nicht im
70 sondern in 186 texten aus faz
produkten auf das ist schon mal ein
kleiner schönheitsfehler zu nicht
andererseits aber auch fast schon wieder
egal denn selbst von den 70 texten hast
du ja nur 15 untersucht weil du
angeblich nur dort eine zentrale rolle
gespielt hast von diesen 15 texten
sollen dann zehn fehler enthalten haben
also 66,7 prozent mehr als bei jeder
anderen zeitung
das ist eine definition von einem fehler
in vielen fällen einfach nur bedeutet
eine meinungsäußerung über mich die mir
nicht gefällt
wir haben wir ja gerade schon
festgestellt aber es geht leider noch
weiter denn du verfügst auch die
stichprobe massiv wer uns sortiert so
zum beispiel total wie groß aus alles wo
du nicht die hauptrolle spielt fliegt
aus einer auswertung raus das war ja
noch okay so hast du es ja auch
angekündigt aber dann schaue ich mir mal
probeweise ein paar texte an die dubai
anderen medien aufgelistet hass und hoch
was ich denn da
ein text auf zeit online über gängigsten
bezug zu dir nahe null
im ganzen text taucht exakt ein einziger
fakt über dich auf und das du deinem cdu
video auf einem bürostuhl gesessen hast
oder auch dieser bericht von spiegel
online über support von youtube an für
dich ein text zu exakt den selben thema
von uns taucht in deiner liste hingegen
gar nicht erst auf ja sogar der bloß
newsletter vom spiegel in dem
verschiedene texte darunter auch einer
zu dir lediglich kurz angekündigt werden
ist nach deiner definition offenbar ein
gehaltvoller artikel in dem du die
hauptrolle spielt und der natürlich
richtig ist und es könnte gut sein dass
der spiegel hier so gut abschneidet weil
er eben eine eigene dokumentation
abteilung hat ja könnte natürlich sein
könnte allerdings auch sein dass das mit
der spiegel dokumentation die jetzt seit
dem reload skandal vielleicht auch ein
kleines bisschen entzaubert ist gar
nicht so wahnsinnig viel zu tun hat
sondern eher damit dass du bewusst oder
unbewusst seine kriterien zur aufnahme
in die stichprobe zwischen verschiedenen
medien nach belieben verändert wenn du
also zum beispiel bei der zeit oder beim
spiegel lauter texte aufnimmst die
wirklich nur minimal mit dir zu tun
haben und bei uns umgekehrt texte wie
diesen hier raus lässt in denen du die
schillernde hauptrolle spielt
danach dass deine von vornherein
unsinnig angelegte und tendenziös
durchgeführte untersuchung endgültig und
vollständig wörtlich so wir sind jetzt
mehr oder weniger am ende angelangt
wie wir gesehen haben gründet ein großer
teil des videos auf schiefen parallelen
zwischen journalismus und
verschwörungstheorien auf suggestionen
und strom an argumenten und natürlich
auf einer untersuchung die schon im
ansatz untauglich ist und außerdem
komplett manipulativ durchgeführt wurde
vieles davon hat jeder der etwas
nachdenkt sofort erkennen können
für anderes musste man halt erstmal ein
bisschen recherchieren und die
behauptungen in deinem excel dokument
überprüfen beides sollte von einer
branche die du mit deinem video ja auch
ziemlich heftig angreifst jetzt
eigentlich nicht zu viel verlangt sein
aber was schreiben die lieben kollegen
so schauen wir uns mal den spiegel an
ihr wisst schon das magazin mit der
großartigen dokumentation das sind rieso
video so gut weg kommt was er sagt
stimmt alles seine recherchen sind
tadellos auch wiebe klingt da fehlen mir
echt die worte oder die rheinische post
jesus video taugt als unterrichtseinheit
für jede journalistenschule denn er
fordert handwerkliche sorgfalt oder
netzpolitik die liste ließe sich
fortsetzen
und was dich an geht lieber rieso einmal
tief durchatmen bitte ich will dass sie
am ende noch mal deutlich sagen das geht
mir mit diesem video nicht darum nun
irgendwie dich zu zerstören und wir
werden dich trotz seiner zahlreichen
falschaussagen bei uns auch nicht
verklagen damit das klar ist dein video
enthält auch viele zutreffende aussagen
gute ansätze zum beispiel zum thema
transparenz und verlinkungen wir
journalisten können tatsächlich vieles
besser machen natürlich ist es super
dass du deine zuschauer für
verschwörungstheorien wahnsinn und die
strategien von verschwörungstheoretikern
and last aber dass du diesen anlass
zugleich auch nutzt um eine persönliche
abrechnung als journalistische
qualitätsanalyse zu verbrämen und uns
und viele andere zeitungen zu unrecht in
die nähe von verschwörungs video logen
zu rücken das konnte so nicht stehen
bleiben und damit ist alles gesagt
[Musik]